the coronavirus pandemic although
very much under control in much of the
world i have friends uh touring belgium
france a lot of different countries
things are you know everybody's wearing
masks on public transit but
it's a very normal life it is not under
control here in the united states in
fact it's spiraling completely out of
control dr anthony fauci said
about a month ago we could be heading
towards 100 000 new cases per day
sounded according to some hyperbolic at
the time doesn't seem like it
and what were originally only spiking
cases
are now starting to be spikes in
hospitalizations
and spikes in deaths and in fact
yesterday july 21st
we had the most deaths in a day
dating all the way back to the second of
june okay
50 days the highest death toll in 50
days
yesterday tragically hospitalizations
have re-surged to essentially
the highest point we've had we're close
to the hospitalization peak of mid april
of course we have this lag time where
first you see cases
then you see hospitalizations then you
see deaths and that is
exactly what we are seeing there were
some people saying the death surge isn't
going to come
most deaths in 50 days 51 days yesterday
so
we're in a race against time here we're
in a race against time when it comes to
a treatment and a vaccine
we're in a race against time when it
comes to removing donald trump and
putting someone there who will just say
doctors need to deal with this not
politicians
but because we've failed to deal with
this
we have much less time than other
countries do hospitals are filling back
up deaths are creeping up icus in
florida texas other hot spots are
anecdotally reporting
being at capacity or close to capacity
our ability to maintain
a lower mortality rate depends on
keeping icus
open with space available hospitals with
space available
many states have that and that's great
many states tragically do not
and the top hot spots continue to be
california texas florida arizona
georgia's now a bigger and bigger piece
of the problem tennessee
the growth rate in idaho is very very
high even though the case numbers
themselves are not yet that high
um the carolinas oklahoma and louisiana
missouri mississippi alabama i mean it's
a it's bad in a lot of the country and
when we look at this not state by state
but by county
um looking at the map that we have up on
the screen for our video audience we see
that there are these
large swaths where things are under
control at the county level
and those are mostly in the northeast
and then in the the
mountain time zone area but then a ton
of orange and red colored counties on
the map
where um cases are not under control
and are getting worse there's a term i
don't know that this is really a term i
i
i'm not saying i created this but i've
been using it i haven't heard other
people use it
it's sort of virus escape velocity
escape velocity the idea
of uh the force required to escape
the gravitational pull of the earth for
um a craft that is trying to exit
earth's gravitational pull we are very
close
to getting to virus escape velocity and
escape velocity when applied to the
virus would be the point at which the
cases are growing so quickly
that even if you immediately shut
everything down like
a full block people don't you know i'm
talking like an authoritarian lockdown
even there you would continue to see a
dramatic spike because there's just so
much so much virus out there and
incubating
if we aren't already there in some of
these states that are hot spots
we are very close and the situation by
august 15th could be
unconscionable is the word i would apply
to it now this is optional i really want
people to remember that
italy was hit early as a hot spot but is
completely under control right now and
life is returning very much to normal
there
switzerland was hit later for people who
say well if you were hit earlier you're
under control but the us was hit later
switzerland was hit later than italy
they are also completely under control
so at this point this has been going on
long enough five months five plus months
the first cases we know were actually in
late december in the us
but you know in a serious way we're
talking about five months
this is no longer about getting hit
earlier or getting hit later
it's now policy it takes about 10 weeks
to flatten and attack the curve
if you do it right we're five months in
every country now has had the chance
many have done it we are every day
building
the pandemic people are desperate to get
back to normal so am i
well everybody's got to put a mask on
you've got to stop the indoor events
you've actually got to do the work
required to do it
and i'm horrified horrified by where we
might be
in 20 days i hope i'm wrong so far
unfortunately if anything
i've been i've been too optimistic in
other words i was thinking you know by
june 1 june 15
we're going to have very few cases
that's the way the models are looking
well we just it was a disaster
people didn't do what we were supposed
to do we didn't have that lull and we
may be heading full
speed ahead into an even bigger it's not
even a second wave just an even bigger
continuation directly into the fall and
flu season so we'll be polling our
audience on our instagram page which is
david pakman show about
what you're doing and what you expect in
the fall so make sure you're following
us there
and we will be back with much more right
after this
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get twenty five percent off a
subscription when you go to blinkist.com
slash pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video